this was a symbol of true power
but today
it means nothing but destruction
[Music]
and all those we used to protect us
[Music]
have now been overwhelmed but that that
was yesterday
[Music]
before we decided that our playgrounds
will now become our battlefields agents
of the strategic homeland division our
highly-trained self-supported tactical
agents hidden among society they're
trained to restore order and to ensure
the continuity of government in case of
a catastrophic emergency but where do
they come from
[Music]
[Music]
division agents live in normal life
secretly within many different areas of
society they continue to live ordinary
lives until the moment that they are
activated the division shouldn't be
compared to an elite military unit in
the traditional sense with military
units are trained for specific tasks and
missions the division are a civilian
agency whose members lay dormant until
the directive 51 is activated anyone has
been following me for a little while
might remember some of the lost agent
videos are released these videos took us
through a number of the missing agents
and the Intel we found in New York City
some of these included Tanisha Carter a
33 year old flight controller from
Philadelphia Joseph as a warzone
cameraman and Michael Trudeau who was a
child prodigy turned professional poker
player understandably the most common
question I keep getting asked was how
our division agents chosen a lot seemed
to have the obvious background in the
military or law enforcement but there
are others that seem to have no combat
or emergency experience whatsoever
[Music]
before we go into how the candidates are
chosen it's probably worth going over
the structure of the strategic homeland
division to better understand how the
recruiters see these candidates as a
good fit for the shd officially
according to the US federal government
the strategic homeland division is
formally listed as part of the
Department of Homeland Security
however they report directly to the
President of the United States and only
commands Field Operations when activated
by the National Security presidential
directive 51 the strategic homeland
division is led by a Board of Directors
there isn't a single centralized
facility that everything is run through
because the shd has been put in place as
a unit that activates in time with
catastrophic emergency having a single
headquarters would leave them vulnerable
to attack or disaster of some kind
instead the rule of three is applied the
Division HQ is located in three
identical bunker facilities called cause
each Corps is independently operated and
managed by a director with the seat on
the board all three cores are located
through the center of the country and
South Dakota Kansas and Texas each Corps
handles routine management and
administrative duties during peacetime
but is able to transition instantly
after a directive 51 activation where
they would coordinate intelligence and
logistics across the division network
within the division there are three main
departments research and development
support and operations the divisions R&D
department builds and supports high
level technical solutions for all agency
field personnel they're responsible for
the development of shd technology the
R&D group also maintains the agency's
weapons field equipment and operations
gear to avoid political intervention or
to keep the organization as covert as
possible the R&D department operate out
of a number of dummy companies the
division Support Group handles routine
tasks related to the organization's
management like communications finance
and human resources
however times of activation the support
department also performs key mission
critical functions such as intelligence
analysis and logistical planning
the operations department coordinates
the deployment and fieldwork of sleeper
agents other than top-secret covert
training exercises agents do not engage
in field work until directive 51 is
invoked operations is divided into three
branches Internal Affairs strategic and
tactical the ideal division agent is
loyal able versatile and fit quick
thinking and the ability to make tough
decisions when needed and adept
problem-solving skills are just some of
what the agency is looking for when
recruiting a new agent a valuable a
troop needed for the division agent is
that they are self-sacrificing and
always put others before themselves for
this reason candidates should have a
background a community or enforcement
areas like health care military law
enforcement and the rescue services but
working in these fields certainly isn't
required agents of the division are
required to be able to execute a wide
range of tasks there must be creative
versatile and dependent and capable of
operating outside the standard rules of
engagement and because of this the
strategic homeland division seeks agents
who come from a number of different
areas in society as long as they're
strong in the attributes standard above
having the diversity of skills within
each cell of agents only adds to the
overall effectiveness of the group and
certain agents among society
they are often activated with very
little knowledge of what's happening
behind the scenes they are free to
determine their mission priorities and
are only bound by the oath of service
and only regulated by the Internal
Affairs branch of the divisions
operation group once activated and then
deployed a division agent outranks all
other tactical units in the fields this
Authority allows agents to bypass laws
regulations and jurisdictional
boundaries as needed they can freely
organize local assets whether it be
civilian or military to help address
local needs the division recruiters are
granted access to a vast database of
restricted information on civilians
collected by the United States
intelligence community this access
allows them to pick from a huge pool of
prospective agents by filtering them
through based on the positions and
requirements put in place ndidates are
drawn from all aspects of society and
are not limited to a specific skill set
or profession
once a candidate's been target a highly
classified vetting process begins
Internal Affairs does a background check
including comprehensive financial and
medical work history and extensive
surveillance of social media networks if
the candidate makes it through the first
line of vetting an experienced division
agent makes contact to organize an
interview if the candidate shows keen
interest in national service and
understands the need for absolute
secrecy
they are then moved on to a rigorous
round of assessments for candidates that
make it thus far there is a number of
tests they're put through this phase is
called pre testing agency psychologists
would run them throughout extension the
number of performance assessments
including virtual reality missions
simulators to see how they would react
in different situations these personal
interviews would also put the candidate
through a number of cognitive and
psychological assessments the results of
this testing produces a comprehensive
candidate evaluation report the report
then scores the candidate in each of the
following fields loyalty mental
resilience judgment and decision-making
field leadership adaptability
problem-solving and the ability to
improvise technical skills and aptitude
commitment to peak physical fitness
immune system health rule survival
instincts throughout this testing the
most important piece that is being
monitored as the mental strength these
agents have potentially been placed in a
situation where they're being pushed to
the absolute limits mentally survival
and crisis management is a mind game
they need to be able to handle it
not all candidates have combat
experience and this is fine but every
agent must exhibit the ability to train
and prepare for the absolute worst case
scenario only at this point a
candidate's considered recruits now
comes the grueling process of full
physical and technical readiness
training however due to the secretive
nature of this role that can be
difficult to achieve this process is
highly demanding yet it cannot put
recruits in situations where suspicions
could compromise the cover so for this
reason most training is disguised and
worked into the recruits daily life
examples of this training are exclusive
black bear only training classes and
neighborhood martial arts studios
high-intensity workouts at local
cross-training jumps with special
instructors who happen to be division
trainers advanced firearms classes or
technology courses at local community
colleges again all taught by division
experts and attended by other recruits
or active agents the division worked
closely with every agent to develop
effective and credible cover stories for
these activities new division agents are
slowly brought into the process of the
day-to-day division agent life this is
to further protect the secrets of the
strategic homeland division during the
first six months of training each agent
is reevaluated weekly for progress
including mental strength and
psychological stability it could take up
to 12 months of intense training before
a new agent has opened up to the
divisions true purpose eventually
recruits in top security clearance and
are certified by the ternal Affairs as
active agents but it doesn't stop here
agents are expected to maintain
year-round training for the length of
their service basic survival skills
combat and intelligence training is
required to be honed through regular
practice in exercise the general
consensus is their agents devote their
spare time to training and preparation
the support department contract civilian
instructors to provide specialist
training and advanced group exercises on
a regular basis on top of this each
local sale of agents are expected to
coordinate and perform regular exercises
and training sessions
once the initial training is complete
new division agents continue with their
daily lives and function as normal
members of society
agents live with our operate once
activated allowing for quick response
times and removing the need for
redeployment the status of division
agents is considered a state secret and
is classified at the highest level
identities and tracking protocols are
only known to the most senior members in
the Pentagon even high-ranking
government officials aren't privy to
this information division agents are
drawn straight from society trained up
and then put right back where they left
off agents from all across the country
and come from a variety of different
workplaces in society there could be
police officers paramedics construction
workers they could even be the guy
selling hot dogs on the corner of the
street because of the requirement of
absolute secrecy around the divisions
existence it can be quite a challenge
for agents who are rejoining society
this is only made harder with the
constant ongoing training and personal
development so there you have it
agent can be selected for anywhere
provided they meet the criteria that the
recruiters are looking for
however it's what comes next that
defines whether they're suitable for the
strategic homeland division a long
period of rigorous testing and
psychological assessments when placed
under the most stressful earth situation
as what truly defines whether a
candidate will be a part of the secret
agency but even after successfully
passing this face the next ongoing
challenge begins friends loved ones no
one can know of the existence of the shd
and their place as an agent within it
with the requirement of ongoing training
and development the agent is expected to
essentially run a second life in secrecy
so what do you think if you were
approached would you go through with it
thanks for watching guys I really
appreciate your viewership I hope you've
enjoyed the video and I'll catch you in
the next one
[Music]